[Música]
hola
qué gusto qué emoción coincidir con
ustedes en este momento pero para que tú
para que yo y para que cada uno de
nosotros llegar a este punto a este
lugar a este encuentro nos antecedieron
muchas conversaciones porque la
conversación nos lleva a la
manifestación la conversación es más
allá de la comunicación comunicamos todo
el tiempo la manera en la que nos
vestimos nos peinamos nos movemos nos
sentamos está hablando quiénes somos y
cómo estamos pero conversar implica una
de las cosas más complicadas para un ser
humano y es escuchar la capacidad de
escuchar dos por tan difícil porque de
repente nos brota el reptiliano esta
parte visceral esta parte que dice mi
verdad es mi propiedad es mi honor así
como mayores quieren tesoro entonces
poder escuchar a alguien más me saca de
ésta visceralidad cuando nos escuchamos
y conversamos nos transformamos
y esto tiene siglos que nos lo han dicho
y no hemos sido como que muy atentos a
este punto en la antigua griega grecia
ya plutarco nos había dicho la
importancia de escuchar de relacionarnos
de poner atención y tiene una frase que
a mí me encanta y que si lo aplicas en
tu vida diaria te puedes transformar y
es que la mente no es una vasija para
llenar la mente es un fuego para atizar
y olvídate de que de repente llenamos la
mente de tantas cosas lo que más me
preocupa es gente que la tiene vacía y
se le nota pero si la mente es algo que
vamos a pisar un fuego que encender como
podríamos encender este fuego como
podríamos sentirnos más vivos y con este
fuego crear porque es la magia del fuego
la transformación no solamente desde la
antigua grecia sino también hace más de
un siglo
rod steiner que fue un gran aportador al
tema de educación que la educación es lo
que nos va a ayudar a transformarnos
como humanidad ya nos decía también de
que para poder impactar influir en los
demás
educar finalmente teníamos que encender
este fuego teníamos que comunicar que
emocionar que conectar que tocar el alma
que hacer vibrar el corazón
para steiner fue muy difícil su época
porque incluso lo tacharon de ocultista
era un hombre muy disruptor muy
adelantado a sus tiempos y digo muy
adelantado porque cuando él hablaba de
la inteligencia del corazón hace más de
un ciclo lo tacharon de loco hoy tiene
más de 20 años que la ciencia nos ha
comprobado que el corazón no es una
bomba de sístole y diástole no es un
músculo el corazón tiene un 65% de
neuronas mucho más vibrantes mucho más
rápidas mucho más intuitivas que las
tenemos en este cerebro así que cuando
nos conectamos al corazón podemos
llevarnos a una manifestación
y si ya tiene más de un siglo y más
recientemente de manera contemporánea
muchos autores bestseller conferencistas
investigadores incluyendo al doctor
massaro en monto nos comprobaron de
manera mucho más palpable como la
palabra por supuesto que impacta que
toca que transforma y cuando viene desde
el corazón hay una manifestación más a
remoto nos comprobó para que lo
pudiéramos ver por si acaso dudábamos
como el poder de la palabra su energía
su vibración su intención tiene una
manifestación que en su caso impactaba
los cristales del agua por si alguien
dudaba y aquí la gran reflexión de todos
los los experimentos de todas las
investigaciones de mazar remoto era
llevarnos a entender que el cuerpo es en
tres cuartas partes agua que está
pasando con nuestras palabras
si te tragarás tus palabras nutrir y us
el alma o podrías intoxicar la además de
que más aro en moto y son muchas
investigaciones otros científicos
incluyendo a bros lipton profundizaron
todavía más y lo que me encanta de la
investigación de lipton es que nos llevó
a ver a observar en el microscopio como
las células del cuerpo se estaban
impactando con la conversación que
tenemos con cada uno de nosotros y el
habla sobre romper estas creencias
desafío a la ciencia así que si el mundo
está cambiando si el clima está
cambiando que estamos esperando los
libros nos comprobó que hay gente que se
cree a su enfermedad abraza su
enfermedad ama su enfermedad y se queda
con su enfermedad de tal manera que
tenemos nosotros la respuesta y en esta
conversación interna donde se veían
impactadas nuestras células viene esta
conversación que yo tengo con todo el
universo sporting que también es un gran
impulsor de la inteligencia del corazón
parte de los científicos del heart mat
de que todo el tiempo los seres humanos
estamos en una conversación con el
universo de qué manera me estoy
comunicando con el universo con la
vibración que traemos con lo que estamos
emitiendo porque el campo
electromagnético del corazón se pueden
medir palpablemente científicamente y
los seres humanos somos capaces de
alterar el centro de la tierra su campo
electromagnético a través de nuestras
emociones como se ha comprobado
científicamente que estamos vibrando
porque atraemos no lo que queremos lo
que tenemos y si tienes miedo vienen más
experiencias que te lo demuestren y si
tienes rabia y coraje vienen más
experiencias que te lo van a demostrar
así que no te quejes de nada porque tú
lo causas tendríamos que ser mucho más
cuidadosos con nuestras palabras si todo
el tiempo estamos conversando con el
universo así que somos responsables de
lo que tenemos
en esta conversación que hay con el
universo pues también hay otro
científico que nos da esta aportación
para decirnos que como especie humana
nos estamos comunicando todo el tiempo
con nosotros y esto viene a reforzar la
teoría de los años setentas del
centésimo mono que ha sido a favor o en
contra a fin de explicar que entre los
individuos de la misma especie cuando
hay una masa colectiva hay una
información que los puede llevar a la
transformación y si nosotros aún lo
dudamos la inteligencia artificial lo
está ocupando de una manera vertiginosa
porque las computadoras conectadas a la
nube se están actualizando todo el
tiempo desde cualquier parte del lugar
compartiendo la información nos llevan
ventaja de hecho uno de los estudios de
la universidad de oxford nos anticipo
desde el 2013 que podríamos estar viendo
en 15 años en un futuro en el que
estamos a punto de alcanzar hasta un
reemplazamiento del 47 por ciento de la
fuerza laboral en este
planeta por la inteligencia artificial
la robotización y la sistematización y
aún aún seguimos esperando no estamos
aplicando todo lo que tenemos porque de
verdad somos la historia que nos
contamos la conversación es una
herramienta sumamente poderosa
transformadora
y justo es lo que eso nos ha hecho falta
no solamente en este país nos hace falta
escucharnos como humanidad nos hemos
dejado de escuchar nos hemos dejado de
importar peor aún de conectar nos hemos
vuelto cada vez más virtuales y parece
que mientras el problema no toca la
puerta de mi casa no existiera pero
tarde que temprano a todos nos va a
alcanzar y cuando digo que somos la
historia que nos contamos no es tanto la
frase romántica que solemos utilizar los
coaches para entender que te cuentas y
cómo lo interpretas es esta confirmación
científica de que cada palabra nos está
impactando nos está nutriendo no se está
comprometiendo no se está transformando
de qué estamos hablando
deberíamos de ser mucho más cuidadoso
con eso porque lo estamos creando y con
los diez años que he tenido la
oportunidad de acompañar a muchos seres
humanos en su transformación a través de
la ontología del lenguaje con lo que es
el coaching la parte de psicoterapia
entendí que más allá de que somos la
historia que nos contamos nosotros
mismos nos vamos diseñando nos vamos
transformando y quise compartir con más
personas con el mayor número de personas
posible lo que yo he visto que
transforma a la persona de la persona
que soy a la que quiero ser y a los
equipos del trabajo de el resultado que
tengo al resultado que quiero tener y
esto es a través de las conversaciones
de tal manera que el año pasado logré la
publicación de palabras para sanar donde
tenemos las conversaciones con
personalidades que son materia autoridad
en la materia que yo considero que es
parte de la enseñanza de la vida y por
donde podríamos empezar a abrir estos
capítulos con qué conversación nos viene
bien a todos los seres humanos pues me
parece que con una que es inevitable en
la vida el loto el dolor es inevitable
el sufrimiento no es el drama de aaa es
ella es opcional pero el dolor es tan
inevitable
que se los quiero comprobar alza la mano
a quien de ustedes le ha tocado pasar
por el duelo de perder a un ser querido
alcen la mano
déjenla arriba alcen la mano aquí en la
han roto el corazón alza la mano los que
no lanzaron son de palo o algo así pero
bueno ok
gracias evidentemente el dolor es algo
por lo que todos vamos a cruzar es
inevitable y el dolor parece que hasta
lo queremos esquivar no pero el dolor en
su etimología tiene algo muy importante
el dolor se refiere a algo que llega te
golpea te pule te transforma y me parece
que uno de los dolores más fuertes que
puede llegar a experimentar un ser
humano sin duda alguna es la pérdida de
un ser querido pero más aún si hablamos
de un hijo entonces en esta materia me
tomé la oportunidad de conversar con
virginia sendel gran comunicadora pero
sobre todo gran impulsora a través de la
fundación michou y mau para salvar vidas
virginia empezó una conferencia a la que
asistí diciendo esta fundación
nació del dolor y después se convirtió
en un acto de amor como podemos
transformar el dolor en amor cuando
tienes justamente esta conversación como
dijera la tanatología que va aplazando
de la negación la negociación a la
aceptación y a la transformación porque
cuando los seres humanos tratamos de
evadir el dolor no lo veo me volteo
vamos a caer tarde que temprano entre
esta evasión en una adicción y la
adicción es de lo más común y no es que
te estés metiendo alguna sustancia
química tenemos conductas adictivas
porque pasas del uso pues todo el mundo
lo hace porque no no del uso al abuso
pues como que ya me gustó y del uso del
abuso llegas a la codependencia yo no
puedo estar bien sin que esté haciendo
esta situación esta relación y con esto
llegamos a la adicción
te estás matando y no lo estás parando y
cuando yo aborde este tema también
hablamos de que adicciones de etimología
podría interpretarse como adicción no
estoy hablando una persona llega a ese
lugar de destrucción porque no hablo no
hablo lo que sintió no hablo lo que dijo
con quién hablamos de nuestro dolor con
quién hablamos de nuestra rabia nuestro
coraje lo que no entendemos lo que no
podemos de nuestro miedo si no lo
hacemos nos estamos enfermando nos
estamos intoxicado y miren que en este
país sabemos de dolor claro que sabemos
de dolor cuando los terremotos nos han
sacudido nos han demostrado de qué
estamos hechos y está recorriendo
después del 19 de septiembre la ciudad
de mexico y estar con ese olor ese aroma
entre veladoras entre nostalgia el frío
que cala y ver al seres humanos que
salían a entregarlo todo como te ayudo
como te apoyo gente que tenía las manos
raspadas de estar moviendo las piedras
que no le importaba arriesgar su vida
que no importaba darlo todo porque
quería salvar a otro por lo menos hacer
mente sentir mejor a otro
y esa fue una conversación colectiva
incluso estas conversaciones colectivas
que tenemos cuando hablamos del silencio
el terremoto fue algo que nos hizo una
reflexión un epicentro que nos sacudió y
entonces yo me preguntaba cuando me
paraba en frente de los edificios y
veías todavía la ropa colgada los
juguetes las cosas yo dije una persona
salió de su casa y nunca regresó pero
alguien regreso y ya no tenía casa cuál
habrá sido la última conversación de esa
persona que dejó pendiente un te amo un
gracias un perdón porque todos tenemos
conversaciones pendientes algunas un
tanto incómodas pero justas esas
conversaciones son las que más nos
transforman cuando me toca hacer
talleres a veces les pregunto a mis
alumnos antes de hablar de asertividad
cuál es la conversación más difícil que
has tenido que enfrentar en tu vida
personal cada uno de nosotros sabe cuál
y algunas me calan cuando me dice
julieta julia te a fin de semana mi
hermano no aparecía y lo fui a buscar y
no lo encontré en ningún hospital lo
encontré en la morgue cuando regresé me
estaciona afuera de mi casa
y dije como le digo esto a mi mamá ya
mis hermanas y otro me dijo julieta la
conversación más difícil que yo tenía
que enfrentar puede hablar con mi hijo
de tres años para explicarle que él él
nunca iba a poder caminar como le dices
esto a un niño todos hemos tenido
conversaciones difíciles en nuestra vida
unas incómodas otras dolorosas y tenemos
otras pendientes pero no se las guarden
porque ni tú ni yo ni nadie tiene
siquiera garantizado regresar a su casa
el día de hoy y cuando hablamos de esta
conversación de dolor de transformación
del terremoto esta me encantó poder
documentar la con el creador de los
topos carlos cienfuegos carlos
cienfuegos es un hombre extraordinario
que en aquel terremoto del 85 él decía
que se topó con la oportunidad de salvar
vidas pero también se topó con una
situación que lo movió y de ahí nacieron
los topos más y julieta después de
rescatar a muchas personas
improvisadamente porque él iba rumbo a
su trabajo cuando pasa esto pero tenía
desde que es niño y uso de razón
el tema de primeros auxilios entró y se
encuentra entre los escombros más
profundos con una mujer embarazada y
esta mujer embarazada por supuesto está
asustada desesperada y dice sácame de
aquí por favor
pero entre carlos y esta mujer hay un
cuerpo un cadáver dice claro que te
quiero sacar pero tengo que cortar este
cuerpo dice julieta no tenía con qué
hacerlo salí a buscar herramientas
después de que estuve media hora con
ella hablándole calmando la hidratándola
y cuando salgo y busco el comandante la
persona a cargo de protección civil me
dice no como crees que vas a cortar un
cuerpo
y ese no se ve a la autoridad creo que
va al ministerio público y julieta obvio
trámite burocrático quienes hemos hecho
alguno me tuvieron dos horas dos horas
ahí sentado para el final salir decirme
hágalo pero no se lo diga a nadie
dice cuando yo regreso y veo la nube de
polvo y veo que con la réplica la
persona fue aplastada esta vez como me
sentí y cuando me lo contaba sentía yo
su coraje su rabia porque su voz suave
pero también cuando conversé con él le
dije que es lo más difícil es salir a
rescatar personas porque el señor
rescató víctimas en el terremoto de
haití
levantó cuerpos cuando fuerce una meta
islandia y me dice con la voz quebrada y
los ojos mojados rescatar un niño
rescatar un niño es lo más difícil
porque me acuerdo de mis nietos rescatar
lo vivo muerto es lo más complicado y su
voz se le quiebra elige carlos carlos
que te cuentas a ti mismo para salir de
tu casa dejar a tu familia cruzar el
océano el mundo lo que sea y rescatar
otra persona y me dice yo me digo a mí
mismo que solamente nos vamos a morir
una vez sabes y prefiero morirme
rescatando una vida
que de un infarto viendo la televisión
qué estamos haciendo nosotros y justo
hay muchas personas haciendo pequeños
actos que hacen la diferencia la
conversación de la generosidad con las
patronas estas mujeres que 24 por 7 más
de 20 años cuando era un delito ayudar
al migrante han rescatado vidas y estar
con ellas y observar como la gente
llegaba sin suelo en los zapatos con
sangre en los pies llorando diciéndome
éramos cuatro llegamos tres y escuchar a
la familia con todas las vejaciones de
lo que pasa cómo matan a los niños
violan a las mujeres con tal de
quitarles lo último que tienen y lo
único que tienen son los sueños en una
mochila con ellas dice la conversación
de la generosidad nos hace falta volver
a pensar en nosotros parece que se nos
olvidó en qué momento es normal ver a
los niños en la calle durmiendo a ver un
drogadicto pero una mujer abusada un
animal maltratado en qué momento es
normal señores
no sé ustedes pero a mí no me gusta
quedarme callada y cuando me invitó
emilio álvarez icaza con quien documente
la conversación de la indignación porque
a mí las cosas me indignan
tuve la oportunidad presentada en el
senado de la republica palabras para
sanar y con esto decir en este lugar
donde se toman las decisiones nos hace
falta escuchar nos hace falta voltear no
saber ser empáticos entender dejar de
criticar dejar de culpar las redes
sociales se han vuelto en eso y es una
vergüenza que no seamos más proactivos
de qué sirve la queja de nada que
estamos construyendo poco entonces
andrés roemer quien me acompañó en la
presentación siempre dice piensa
diferente por dios piensa diferente no
te quedes con lo mismo
pensábamos que la tierra era plana y no
fue que el sol era el centro del
universo y no fue hoy que estamos
pensando y no es nos urge pensar
diferente pero más allá de pensar que
vamos a ser diferente que podemos
cambiar tú puedes cambiar muchas cosas
ni siquiera tienes que ser figura
pública pero todo depende de la
conversación que tenemos con nosotros
mismos nos urge ser más consciente a qué
le digo si con eso me comprometo a que
le digo no
de que ya basta palabra que me encanta
pero sobre todo que es lo que no sé y me
abro aprendes porque cuando yo digo no
se me habló hacerlo diferente si no hay
verdades absolutas si aquí mismo ustedes
van a ver el día de hoy personas con
ideas diferentes yo espero que no
solamente se las queden para llenar la
mente y como decía plutarco es que se
enciendan que lo prueben que cuando te
atreves a ver algo diferente abres todas
las posibilidades y cuando escuchábamos
esta palabra abracadabra se acuerdan no
hacíamos referencia a la magia si
abracadabra viene del arameo para cada
vara que significa yo creo a través de
la palabra todos y cada uno de nosotros
sí sí tenemos una varita mágica sí sí
tenemos la capacidad de manifestar
debemos de ser mucho más conscientes que
es lo que estamos creando así que si la
mente no es un recipiente para llenar yo
espero que lo que ustedes tomen en el td
encienda su fuego interior porque el
agua estancada se pudre la gente está en
casa se enferma así que hay sentados o
quejándonos no vamos a lograr nada así
que les voy a pedir que para que se
puedan conectar a que su mente no se
llene se transforme y sientan la sangre
que corre en sus venas por favor se
pongan de pie un segundo pónganse de pie
pongan su mano izquierda en el corazón
escúchenlo por favor y dense cuenta que
solamente cuando nos escuchemos y
conversemos como sociedad como
empresarios como gobierno vamos a
transformar no solamente este país sino
la humanidad que ya no aguanto más así
que me va a encantar que hagas
abracadabra uses tus palabras para
encender tu fuego interior y que eso se
sienta muy bien que vibre y converse es
mejor que en el universo y eso cómo se
siente muchachos
o lo que sea escuchar un ruido más
grande cómo se siente
los invito a que encendamos el mundo con
nuestra propia luz a través de las
palabras la magia está en las palabras y
en cada uno de nosotros muchísimas
gracias
[Música]